think the apocalyptic narrative is
incredibly dangerous and is a is a means
of political control so it's you know
fear-mongering and especially in the
world that is completely secular
um watch the Western world is becoming
more and more so it has really taken I
feel the place of a new religion but not
in a in none of the good senses of you
know the word
um so
I think people are very susceptible to
the idea of
finding meaning through you know
preserving the planet and saving the
world in that sense so they're more
focused on the creation than on the
Creator so to say and I think that
that's dangerous because that can be
used for that can be abused and misused
by people who have a different agenda
that is actually way more sinister